one of the things I aim for in the
course
to show some students in in in ways as
concrete and rich as I can what the
authority or power of movies in a
cultural moment might be and I try to
give them some examples of that in my in
my first lecture I sometimes read to
them from a passage from James ag's
novel a death in the family in the very
beginning of that novel he describes
beautifully a an excursion between a
father and son going to see a Chaplin
comedy in 1915 and in some southern city
and what he describes is what a social
occasion it was what a moment of bonding
it was for father and son what a
cultural moment it was more broadly for
the whole of the population that went
into the theater to laugh uproariously
at Charlie's shenanigans and then the
screen was filled with a city and with a
sidewalk of a side street of a city and
a long line of palms and there was
Charlie
everyone laughed the minute they saw him
squat lay walking with his toes out and
his knees apart as if he were chafed
Rufus's father laughed and Rufus laughs
- laughs - this time Charlie stole whole
a whole bag this time what does that
imply about the audience an intimate
familiarity with previous adventures of
this character right an ongoing routine
connection this time he caught a sight
at this time Charlie stole a whole bag
of eggs and when a cop came along he hid
them in the seat of his pants and what
it showed was the cultural embeddedness
of movies even in their earliest days in
the society and in the life of
individuals so part of what I mean by
the power of movies and what I try to
encourage the students to see is
something of this anthropological energy
as well as its artistic power as a
representation of human experience that
the way these kinds of stories permeated
the society helped to shape America's of
Americans understanding of their natures
of what the social fabric was like of
what masculinity was of what femininity
was of what families were of what the
relations among the races were of what
American history was about what the
Founding story of America is about what
the central organizing values of our
culture are all of
those things are dramatized either
explicitly or implicitly in movies and
because the movies were so central
through the 20th century they were one
of the central ways in which the belief
system the values of American society
were promulgated dramatized rehearsed
and in some ways altered and changed a
related matter that I connected again to
film in part as an anthropological or
sociological phenomena not simply an
artistic one as a social practice in a
way has to do with the power and role of
genre in movies which is a recurring
theme in my course because we use genre
in American society I think all cultures
do this but we've made particularly rich
and cunning use of genre in American
society in in many media but especially
in film and if you look at particular
long lives on or like the Western or the
detective story or the domestic
melodrama over time what you of course
can recognize are changing cultural and
social attitudes the soul of Western has
become a screen on which America's
anxieties about the Vietnam War have
been projected why would the Western
work so well for this one answer is what
I've been saying all along about the
power of genre and the power of
repetition look if I think is repeated
again and again and again it looks
familiar when it's so familiar what
happens it licenses something disturbing
because it's so because the genre it
seems on the surface to contain so many
familiar reassuring elements those very
elements of reassurance enable the
exploration of disturbing or uncertain
or or problematic materials and that's
one of the Rhian dov course because any
any note not any one of these films
would have nothing like the power they
actually have if they existed
individually but it's because they're
part of this long conversation that goes
back to the earliest days of movies that
they have the power that they have one
of the functions of genre is one of the
deep subjects of mice of my course and I
want students to see how centrally
variations in genre forms can reflect
social and historical realities and you
can feel this in every film you can feel
this in every television program if you
look at American television from the
1950s to the 1990s one let's say you
restricted yourself to situation comedy
what do you think you would see you
would see a drama in which the American
family undergoes profound change what
happens women become more important
patriarchal values become less and less
powerful children become more respected
less letlet are treated less less like
appendages to the family more to some of
them sudden and in some by the 80s and
90s sometimes the children have more
dominant roles than the adults and are
often even shown to be wiser than their
parents right something that would have
been impossible in the early 1950s more
patriarchal era when the classic
television program about families was
called father knows best
another spine question or organizing key
question in the course is deeply
literary for me in other words what I
try to do here is encourage the students
to develop what I'll call an aesthetic
sense to begin to have confidence when
they say that's a good film or that's a
bad film I think that's a good movie I
think that's a bad movie I think that's
a good and what I try to tell them is
that that judgment good or bad isn't
merely subjective it isn't just what you
feel right that there may be a
potentially objective standards by which
we can judge the excellence of texts
part of it may remain subjective but we
can still judge excellence when we see
acting we can judge excellence when we
ask how well the film is edited we can
judge it the excellence of various
aspects of the of the film and and
teaching students how to do that and to
distinguish between effective and
ineffective uses of the medium turns out
to be not simply a skill that you give
to students who are watching movies it's
a skill you can give to students who
read poems who read books who go to
plays so one of the central principles I
tried to teach them about this how they
can distinguish
what I call a work of art from a mere
entertainment is what I call the
multiplicity principle and what I mean
by the multiplicity principle is fairly
clear and I give many examples in the
course essentially it's the idea that
what happens in a particular moment will
have multiple functions you won't just
look at the scene in order to have the
plot extended the scene will also
dramatize character it will also tell
you something about the atmosphere in
which the character lives do you
remember the moment in the passage I
showed you from from the De Sica movie
Umberto D that very brief moment where
we see a man get on a get on a tram a
bus and sit next to someone on the bus
and the bus moves there it's a
completely wordless sequence and there's
a character we've never seen in the film
before who sits down next to the
protagonist no words exchanged when our
protagonist gets up and gets off the bus
the camera lingers briefly on the man
he'd left behind and we see that man go
like this and what I suggested to you
again I suggested that this was a moment
of richness and and and complexity of
multiplicity in a way because one
implication of that scene was that the
man this stranger that we'll never meet
again that we only saw for one brief
instant in the course of the film might
have concealed a story as deep as rich
and as moving as that of our hero
Umberto D when a text contains when a
moment contains multiplicity when it
does many things simultaneously you're
in the presence of a kind of excellence
that's only one principle but it's a
very valuable principle and you can see
it's worth if you compare let's say a
trivial or relatively banal form of
action entertainment on the one hand
with a movie that has complex characters
in it and you can see the different
kinds of demands or even that a serious
action-adventure film a film that
incorporates action-adventure elements
in it but also has a serious subject
matter two ones that don't let's say
Kurosawa's samurai movies against the
trivial merely entertaining samurai
movies that didn't weren't interested in
history or character right what you try
to do is do
the students a greater and greater
sensitivity not just to the particular
texts that exhibit such excellence but
you want to arm them so that when they
encounters things on their own they'll
be able to make this judgment a second
aspect of this
excellence this what I call artistic
quality is the quality of organic form I
talked about this again and again in the
course and try to show them instances of
it at its simplest level the pro the
term of course derives from Coleridge
who borrowed it from the German
romantics but essentially it's the idea
that every text should generate a form
that is unique to its needs forms should
be in other words you should not have a
prior form into which content is is it's
poured right the form of the text the
shape of the text should take its nature
from the meaning of the text from what
the text is saying and if you think
about the structure of modern times
you'll see that it's a marvelously
distilled instance a marvelously clear
instance of the principle of organic
form what happens to Charlie serially is
more meaningful in a way than what
happens to him in a single episode and
the fact that it's that we have this
sense that things are repeating that
Charlie's on a treadmill that he lives a
cyclical life that he'll always have
moments of hope and hopelessness that
he'll have momentary times when he's
free of what he's when he finds a place
to live or find sufficient food but then
it will always be temporary that his
life is that his life is always on the
road that his life is always in process
that's and that at the same time he
never lets himself completely despair
he's oh there's always a moment where
his resilience reasserts himself or
reassert reasserts itself
well those elements are embedded in some
sense in this very structure the very
organization of the film there should be
a symbiotic relationship a marriage a
linkage between form and content between
the way the shape of the text between
the strategies and techniques that are
used to embody the story and what the
story says there should be a a marriage
between form and content that's what
organic form is
and if you can show students moments of
organic form and if they can really
recognize it they are proof for life
against banal art